- Tonight on Clock
Ticking on a Screen,
we'll investigate the
question that has been
baffling limited Spanish
speakers for generations.
That's right, we
will finally answer:
Donde esta la biblioteca?
I began my search at the place
with the biggest
concentration of people
who've taken seven years
of Spanish and forgot it,
Brooklyn, New York.
Although this was
a traditionally
Spanish speaking neighborhood,
it seemed to me that
things had changed.
No one seems to have an answer
and I was stuck.
So I decided to ask an expert.
This is Ken Bray.
Bray has spent his entire
adult life obsessively
trying to figure out,
donde esta la biblioteca?
Ken is also an expert in many...
(multiple conversations)
Do you guys mind?
I'm doing the biblioteca
walk and talk.
- Okay.
- Thank you, no big deal.
It's fine, thank you.
Many consider Ken the
premiere biblioteca expert,
while others think he's a
conspiracy theorist gone mad.
He also happens
to have the voice
of a sweet vulnerable
nightingale.
♪ Donde esta la biblioteca?
So Ken, you've spent
you entire adult life
searching for la biblioteca.
Are you any closer
to finding it?
- Of course.
The signs are everywhere.
Open your eyes.
- I'm sorry.
- I want you to
look at this dollar.
Do you notice anything?
- No.
- How about if I take
this dollar and I
fold it three times,
now what do you see?
- A Dorito.
- A symbol for la biblioteca.
Have you seen this
symbol before?
- I can't say that I have, no.
- Have you seen the inside
of a dictionary, before?
- Of course, everybody has.
- Same symbol.
Have you see Cool Runnings?
- I have.
- It's been sitting on my
DVR for like three weeks
and I can't find
time to watch it.
- You must.
- Everybody keeps
telling me to watch it.
- Uplifting,
uplifting yet comedic.
- Cuba Gooding.
- Cuba Gooding,
he's not in that.
- Shit.
- I didn't know what to believe.
So, I decided to go
straight to the source,
where it all began.
Now Mrs. Lopez, you've
taught Spanish for 25 years,
is that right?
- Yes.
It is my life long passion.
- Wonderful.
Now isn't it true
that the first thing that
you teach your students is,
donde esta la biblioteca?
- Yes, it's important to know.
- Wonderful.
Now where is la
biblioteca, Mrs. Lopez?
- Oh, I don't know.
Would you like a cookie?
- I really shouldn't.
Mrs. Lopez, where did
you get that tattoo?
What's going on here?
Hold on.
- This interview is over.
- Your English is
impeccable, woman.
I know that symbol.
The people deserve
to know the truth.
(speaking Spanish)
- Oh, bathrooms and puppies, eh?
What do they have to
do with one another?
Logically, it doesn't
make any sense.
I'm going to get to
the bottom of this.
- Uh, huh, uh, in Espanol.
- Okay, (stuttering)
(speaking Spanish)
- Ooh, muy bien.
- Gracias.
- You're a dead man.
- No.
- I had to figure out
how it was all connected,
so I gathered every
resource I could.
I knew I had to go deeper.
That monkey's evil Dora
and we both know it.
And like any good reporter, I
decided to use my surroundings
and interview one of
Mrs. Lopez's students.
Do you know where I
can find la biblioteca?
- Why don't you just
ask a Spanish person?
Shitty, Bruno Mars.
- You're right.
- [Boy] Ow.
- Thank you.
- Dick.
- Sir, do you know
where la biblioteca is?
- La biblioteca?
- Yes.
- Of course.
It's right over.
No, not again.
(exciting music)
- Mrs. Lopez, stop that.
Stay right there.
(exciting music)
Mrs. Lopez.
It looks like for now, the
whereabouts of la biblioteca
will remain unknown.
- Excuse me, sir,
can you wrap it up?
The library's closing
in five minutes.
- Oh, I'm so sorry.
Lost track of time.
Let's wrap it up boys.
All of you.
And you too, you're
part of my crew.
- Tonight on Solving
Things in a Trenchcoat,
we'll examine the
disappearance of Walter Odina,
also we'll find out
quien es Pablo
and why is he
always by la playa?
Tune in.
Exit's this way.